marielle de sarnez bonjour je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
son plateau que tu as tout compris vous
êtes vice présidente du mouvement
démocrate de françois bayrou centriste
députée européenne depuis 16 ans que
fait l'europe que doit-on faire pour
l'accueil des migrants nos collégiens
ont beaucoup de questions à vous poser
c'est la séquence interview bonjour
bonjour à tous d'abord ont joué à la
hauteur
j'ai une petite question elle dit pour
vous est-ce une bonne chose d'accueillir
c'est le migrant en france c'est un
sujet compliqué ce qui est en train de
se passer
il faut qu'on distingue feront appel
migrants de ce qu'on appelle réfugiés
parce que ce sont pas les mêmes
personnes qui n'ont pas les mêmes droits
l'on peut trouver ça injuste mais il ya
les migrants qui viennent pour des
raisons économiques
donc cela effectivement les appelle les
migrants et puis elle est réfugié et
réfugiés politiques ceux qui fuient la
guerre dans leur pays à qui on doit la
ville mais il faut juste un mot la
france reçoit très très peu de réfugiés
au jour d'aujourd'hui un moine famille
c'est juste un chiffre moins d'un mille
îles allemagne en a reçu plus d'un
million
vous voyez hein c'est disproportionné
mais pour vous c'est légitime pour ces
réfugiés d'être accueillis et de
recevoir l'asile
bien sûr on a le droit le devoir de les
aider après on peut pas accueillir tout
le monde ça c'est une autre question est
donc évidemment qu'il faut des
frontières qu'ils soient contrôlés qui
sera gardée qu'ils soient surveillées
comme l'angleterre par exemple
mais l'angleterre le problème de calais
tu as parlé tout à l'heure on a vu les
images elles sont terribles d'abord de
se dire qu'en france on voit une jungle
comme ça les gens marcher dans la boue
tous les camps de réfugiés du monde vous
mettez simplement je ne sais pas des
gravillons par terre pour éviter la boue
vous mettez des tentes
vous pouvez avoir quand même des
conditions humanitaires qu'ils soient
respectées et le problème de calais
c'est qu'au fond on gère la frontière
pour les anglais ils veulent pas aller
en france qui sont à calais ils veulent
aller en grande bretagne moi je
considère que l'europe n'est pas à la
hauteur de tout ça au jour d'aujourd'hui
pensez vous que dans ce flux migrants
dans ce flux migratoires il y aurait pas
des gens mal intentionnés qui pourrait
justement poser problème
on peut jamais dire que c'est impossible
donc à ce que le 13 novembre a été un
choc
il y avait des terroristes qui
quelques-uns étaient venus par on va
dire par la syrie la turquie la syrie
quelques uns étaient venus de belgique
on peut aussi être terroriste en france
alors voilà oui bien sûr qu'il peut y
avoir quelques individus mais il ya
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on se dise
tous c'est que ce que cherchent les
terroristes c'est justement à nous
diviser
ils cherchent à abîmer la société le
pays conforme hélas la réponse c'est de
se serrer les coudes
même si on sait que c'est pas c'est pas
du tout un moment facile ce que vous
pensez que cet accueil des réfugiés se
fait au détriment du lait de sdf et aux
pauvres non je pense pas du tout parce
que d'abord je t'ai dit les chiffres
tout à l'heure la france il faut le
savoir
elle accueille très peu de réfugiés il
ya près de cinq millions de réfugiés
dans les pays voisins donc énormément de
personnes ont quitté la syrie et donc
c'est quelque chose qui devrait pas
concerner que l'europe mais qui devrait
concerner tous les pays au fonds
développer et moi je trouve que des pays
comme les etats-unis comme le canada le
canada vient de promettre dans la
cueillir quelques dizaines de milliers
comme l'australie comme la nouvelle
zélande enfin je pouvais faire la liste
de tous les pays du monde au fond comme
l'amérique latine devraient participer
de cet accueil
il devrait pas ça ne devrait pas
concerner que l'europe mais il faut
surtout il faut qu'on revienne à
l'essentiel
il faut que tous les pays du monde
toutes les grandes puissances on va dire
etats unis europe russie toutes les
grandes puissances régionales qui ont
partie liée au conflit se mettent autour
de la table pour régler le conflit en
syrie parce que c'est ça la réponse est
la meilleure rédigé d'après vous faudra
faire quoi une pétition une
manifestation clé faut faire quoi pour
faire comprendre au gouvernement parce
que mais allez-y
ça n'a pas l'air trop de bouger enfin je
dis ça je dis rien alors on va dire en
france nous aider qui avait très peu
d'arrivées
vous savez pourquoi il ya très peu
d'arrivées aussi parce qu'il faut aussi
tout un essai on se dit les choses
vraiment ce qu'elle a et fuji veulent
pas venir en france par part dans
d'autres attentats
non mais non
l'hôtel par peur de ne pas être bien
accueilli ça c'est possible mais parce
qu'ils ont peur de ne pas trouver
d'emploi et donc ils se disent en
allemagne c'est une économie qui
fonctionne dans les pays du nord de
l'europe
ce sont des économies qui fonctionne et
c'est terrible de se dire que notre pays
la france bien finalement ils sont très
très rares ceux qui demandent à venir
on parle de ça aujourd'hui maintenant
mais c'est pas le gouvernement qui va
regarder cette émission c'est pas on
sait jamais si vous arrêtez pas dire ce
qu'il faudrait faire mais vous parlez
très peu des moyens par lesquels vous
souhaitez y arriver mais moi je suis pas
le président la république
oui mais je ne suis pas le pouvoir au
parlement européen on a fait beaucoup
c'est à dire que nous avons nous étaient
d'accord sur le fait qu'il fallait une
répartition entre l'ensemble des pays
européens
mais c'est pas nous d'ailleurs qu'il
décide où nous on est un parlement dont
on donne un certain nombre d'idées on
vote un certain nombre de textes on
préconise des directions mais ensuite
c'est ce sont les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais les chefs d'état
gouvernement
quelquefois ils sont pas spontanément
courageux et donc notre responsabilités
la mienne la vôtre la note globalement
masse et de les pousser à être courageux
20 et ça il faut qu'on le fasse
à mon avis c'est là où il était attendu
maël sans raison va devoir s'arrêter là
moi j'ai on a une question à vous poser
à vous d'ailleurs est-ce que vous en
avez eu d'imposer à ces jeunes la
question que j'ai apposé c'est oui si
vous aviez des réfugiés écrivez dans
votre ville
à poitiers de jeunes réfugiés qui
parlerait pas français est-ce que vous
soyez prêts à donner de votre temps ce
que vous vous soyez parties prenantes
oui je pense que en donnant vraiment du
temps même si ça reste assez pop se
serait de l'humanitaire et ce serait ce
serait beau chaque heure on est assez
pour astra 1 tb voilà ça c'est une
réponse que peut-être les responsables
locaux à poitiers ils peuvent entendre
les enfants français que vous êtes
pourrait aussi les accueillir non ça
serait bien ça pourrait changer notre
mode de vie après ça changerait beaucoup
de choses et tu sais qu'ils vont
apprendre des choses puis tu va leur
apprendre des choses quand je dis on
peut pas accueillir tout le monde
mais que ceux qu'on accueille on fasse
le boulot correctement et la part du
boulot vous pouvez aussi en
en prendre une pour l'accueil des
enfants on vient de le voir à la salle
pas on peut voir qu'ils veulent
apprendre ils veulent cesser le
reportage sur l'enfant il veut être à
l'école il veut apprendre parce qu'il a
envie de faire quelque chose bien sûr
c'est là dessus sur cette belle idée de
solidarité qu'on va commencer par et
marianne2 merci à vous tous merci à
venir si nous on va passer un petit jeu
pour terminer ça vous dit